la primera visita diploma chica de alto
nivel de Estados Unidos a China en 5
años Anthony blinkan está en Beijing
para intentar retomar el diálogo con el
país asiático su visita prevista
inicialmente para febrero fue aplazada
después de que Estados Unidos
descubriera un presunto globo de
vigilancia chino en su espacio aéreo el
evento había agravado las tensiones ya
presentes entre ambos países que se
libran una feroz batalla comercial desde
el mandato de Donald Trump
para mantener su hegemonía en ciencia y
tecnología militar Estados Unidos ha
generalizado repetidamente el concepto
de seguridad nacional abusando del poder
Estatal reprimiendo a las empresas
chinas destruyendo intencionadamente el
orden económico y comercial
internacional y las normas del comercio
mundial y poniendo en grave peligro la
estabilidad de las cadenas industriales
y de suministros mundiales ya Hemos
llegado a un punto de histeria el
estatus es otro punto de confrontación
entre las dos potencias china considera
La Isla como una de sus provincias y
amenaza con invadir la militarmente
mientras que Estados Unidos defiende su
independencia la visita de la entonces
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes Nancy pelosi en agosto de
2022 había provocado la ira de Beijing
Anthony blinken espera poder abordar el
calentamiento global y la lucha contra
el fentanilo sustancia que contiene
componentes químicos importados de China
incluso yoda identificó esperar reunirse
pronto con el presidente
Espero que los próximos meses vuelva a
reunirme con She y hablemos de nuestras
legítimas diferencias pero también de
las áreas en las que podemos llevarnos
bien
sin embargo china es más tímida respecto
a las posibilidades de acercamiento y
culpa a Estados Unidos por los desafíos
que enfrentan